happy Friday reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm gonna watch the final trailer for
stranger things season 3 this morning I
edited uploaded our Chuckie movie review
was so excited to talk about it I was
looking through my notifications I did
not have one for Netflix however I saw
several reaction channels I follow have
one and I was like oh damn this totally
flew over my head did not catch any of
this I am insanely late to the party on
this one anywho we're still
contemplating whether or not we're gonna
cover it when it comes out it's gonna be
a crazy week that's spider-man far from
home 4th of July obviously John still
needs to finish stranger thing the
season 1 pinch season 2 as I wouldn't
want to cover it without him if we do it
we'll do that thing where we do reaction
highlights on YouTube and then we'll do
stream along for our patreon page
transition go check out our patreon page
folks really appreciate all the support
we've been getting over there really
does help out the channel a lot and we
got plenty of content we do weekly q and
A's TV show reaction stream along for
many shows that includes of course
attack on Titan my hero academia Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood one punch
man supernatural Gotham haunting of Hell
House Cobra Kai season to several those
shows have reaction highlights included
you've heard me mention it before attack
on Titan my hero academia one punch man
in Supernatural and Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood gotta make this quick cause
I'm gonna go on Collider movie talk in
just a couple hours 3:30 p.m. Pacific
Standard Time but loved it if you chime
in in the comments the livestream and
he'll finally get to this
toys 3 4 and now Wow
you are going to have to let us stay
doesn't make sense listen an arrogant
Athleta state
[Music]
what if he never left
response forgot nipples walked in here
with us
you only attach yourself to someone
again
a new host oh [ __ ]
[Music]
we have to stop
slingshot
[Music]
Wow we're going to end you we're going
to end your friends then we are going to
end every kind of sounds like Jake music
kids are in danger
[Music]
I need to see
[Music]
Oh Nancy
[Music]
oh dude this whole first of all secrets
gonna be crazy
oh man
looks like a freaking movie doesn't it
Jesus Christ definitely got a much
bigger budget this time around holy crap
like looking at a freaking film that was
crazy crazy
well definitely the experimentation
stuff whatever the lab and all the
things that are doing that's that's got
to be underneath them all right that's
just what it all seems like it's
alluding to it's all gotta be underneath
them all I hear just some quick thoughts
quick thoughts as I got to make quick
the voice over here sounds kind of like
Jake Busey's voice I love Jake boosie's
work I like him more than Gary Busey
actually I loved him in the frighteners
he was a great villain and that but I
also saw every season of the El Rey
Networks from dusk till dawn I thought
he was really good in that show too you
don't see him in this trailer but I know
there was like a glimpse of him I think
in the last one overall this trailer
just has beautiful shots throughout that
are so cinematic you have that one shot
very early on where it looks like
Elevens and the upside down surrounded
by like the cloudy snowstorm and she's
in the dead center it's kind of like
she's into like the center of an eye in
that moment she's being watched I love
that or when she's at the beach and all
that stuff is going on the distance and
just more shots that are out that just
look absolutely amazing this whole
concept they have already they tease
that scene between will and 11:00 where
he's saying what if he never left would
it be locked him out here with us that's
a scary concept it's a creepy concept
because they do show that flashback
image of season two when eleven locks
the gate so having that oh man we
thought we were fine but we actually
sort of made things worse and allowed
this power to grow they were talking
about that he's trying to build
something here which just seems like
it'll be super scary stuff maul sequence
that's been getting teased like the
malls gonna be this great beautiful
attraction gonna be a wonderful location
looks like we're gonna get like two epic
sequences one with the mall when this
[ __ ] shows down and then you have the
one of the carnival were shits gonna go
down and I feel like those will be like
their big-money moments in the season so
I'm really excited to see how they
execute those sequences the idea
attaching a Billy makes his character
that much better because I thought dr.
Montgomery I think that's his name Red
Ranger
thought he was really good in season two
I thought his performance was great I
overall felt that character was a little
bit unnecessary for the season there was
a lot of focus give it to him but I
didn't feel like it overall blended
perfectly well with the entirety of
season two in the main story at hand so
if the original intention if it was
always the intention to keep his
character around really build up that
this guy's an [ __ ] this is like
pretty much an evil dude and then you
make him the main villain linked with
these you know sci-fi creatures in
season 3 that makes his character more
rewarding and I feel like overall would
make his development in season 2 that
much better as well and I like that when
you can do sort of a sequel or a
follow-up season that when you go back
to season 2 you're like oh we're never
mind that was actually well worth it I
like these little moments that you're
getting with will and 11 there's a
couple of shots here where you know will
is getting goose bumps on the back of
his neck and there's two of these shots
so maybe that's like his level of
intuition Oh feeling like something's
coming the moment - were Will and Millie
Bobby Brown 11 are interacting with each
other that got me excited when I think
of stranger things I don't really
imagine 11 interacting with will they
have the closest connection to the
upside down in this whole other
mythology and world them having more
scenes together and a deeper sort of
emotional understanding towards one
another I think would be great and I
would like them to have more scenes
Lucas's updated look he's got this link
shot he's got the the bandana it's kind
of Karate Kid Rambo reference I don't
know what year this is taking place in
but those are eighties movies right it
kind of makes sense to look that way and
Elevens powers though those ending shots
than were she's like just it looks like
her powers are really gonna be pushed to
the limit here is everything about this
just looks great man I'm excited check
it out I'm not gonna try to fear eyes
too much on the first trailer reaction
which you guess and go back and watch I
did lay down a lot of different theories
that I sort of have towards it for this
time around I just kind of want to go in
and see what happens one thing I love is
that stranger things doesn't have it's
not based on a book I know it's inspired
by a lot of 80s nostalgia stuff it's not
based on comics or anything be
able to be swept up in this world lends
itself to a lot of surprises because
there's not this prior lore to go off of
I'm correct about that right if I'm
wrong please correct me right away and
I'll say it again you got Cary Elwes
here is the mayor he's got to be a bad
guy right they just only make sense that
he's a bad guy
Cary Elwes famous for playing the doctor
wannabe stepfather and liar liar
opposite Jim Carrey he's done nothing
else unfortunately that's his biggest
work and if you take me seriously on
that you're right too and last thing
I'll say is it just me or is music in
movies and shows just getting so much
better like holy crap I don't know if
it's just in the past year or two I've
been noticing it a lot more I mean even
with Game of Thrones which was very
divisive season one thing everyone could
agree on was the damn music in that
season was great and the music in this
trailer is just so for a visuals season
I'm super excited the most I've been
excited for stranger things based off
its visuals the end of the day
everything comes down to good
storytelling any whom make sure to catch
me on Collider movie talk a little bit
later today subscribe to the reel
rejects click that notification bell if
you liked this video hit the like button
also check us out on patreon for all
them stuff I got a ghost shower now